I have a question related to my business
so yeah what would be your reaction if
somebody send an email which was like
they edited a one-minute video from your
YouTube videos and said put this on your
Instagram and it will do good like those
videos that Gary Vee does on Instagram
mhm someone sent you free free Instagram
content that they edited from your
YouTube videos and they said I'll work
for you for free I'll send you seven
videos a week what would be your
reaction like for that person if it was
good I would love it and this is what
actually happened to me a while back I
forget how long it's been it's probably
over two months I had a different style
on my ig I had like a white picture
every day a black picture every day and
and a picture with like a click here
every day
my format would be these columns so
every third post would be this white
picture that you'd see this nice white
background nice black background so it's
a different style and and I designed the
layout myself and then my team took over
for most of posts in the content and
then somebody in my network emailed me
said hey I have this idea for a new
layout for you for Instagram okay cool
let me see and it actually looked pretty
good I don't know if you followed like
my format now but like some of the
pictures that the hand goes through
multiple pictures the face goes through
multiple pictures so that was that was
his idea and I said that's really cool
I'd love to work together
I do six times a day he's like yeah I
want to do it I want to help you and so
he showed me what it would look like one
by one like he was the first post he's
the second post and he said you can
match my style my brains like it's a
good it's a cool concept but you're a
little bit off in terms of what I would
need and so we went through multiple
revisions that was all free to see if he
can get my brand and then as soon as he
got my brand okay great how much he
charged a month and I never posted
anything that he gave me
that was free because it wasn't quite
matching my brain to what I needed but
but then he took over my entire
Instagram and so we're working together
he sends me every day what the contents
gonna be and I approve it but the style
the design is almost a hundred percent
him and that became because because he
reached out to me but here's the thing
lots people reach out to me most of the
stuff they make isn't actually good so
your thing has to be good I've seen like
a lot of people don't deliver with value
like they don't lead with value so what
I do is my strategies I target like the
life coaches on YouTube like the
successful life coaches most of them
don't have a very good Instagram so I
create I take their life coaches videos
and I create one-minute videos for their
Instagram I send them for free and say I
can make this video for you every week I
can send you three videos four videos
every week
I will know that I work for you for free
so what do you think is that a good
strategy so I think one is about timing
I think if that person the guy that I
work with now if he messaged me a year
ago I wouldn't have said yes because
Instagram wasn't something I cared about
at the time so I started picking up my
Instagram game and then and then it
became more important to me and I was
looking for resources for help for
people to to give me value
I still do it on my youtube channel by
the way like if people send me videos
just most people can't make great stuff
like if you made me a 10-minute believe
video that was fire I would post it but
most people just can't produce at that
level so it's about first finding the
person who actually cares about their
Instagram like they're posting more
there in their comments they're paying
attention like look at their comments
see if they're actively being involved
in there so if they really actually care
about growing this thing look if they're
promoting their Instagram like I said of
talking about Instagram Oh YouTube
channel so that's me momentum around
them build the nerd segrand otherwise
most
we'll treat Instagram as a as a
secondary thing most most of the coaches
it's not their main way of building
their business or they've hired some
some company to do it for them and and
they don't they don't care about it
personally that's gonna be the biggest
challenge of all for you is the
targeting finding the person who really
cares about growing their Instagram in a
big way right now
then it's can you make a good video like
that without one-minute video is it
actually fire is it is it something that
would be proud to share it's a great
strategy I don't think you need to even
work for free if it's good like you can
make the first one for free as your way
in but if they love you they'll pay you
to do it what do you think well what
kind of like should I be reaching to
like as many people as I can every day
targeted people if you're gonna make
time to go make a video you want to make
sure that you've done some research on
that person and then you can bring them
value and you think that they're a good
target for you so looking through their
accounts I think if you're targeting
business coaches I would look at like
there's a lot of people call themselves
a business coach who don't have any
success so it's hard to really yeah yeah
that's why I'm like right now I'm only
targeting people with YouTube
subscribers who have more than 50k
subscribers like coaches with more than
50 years of swagger so they would
definitely be interested if you want to
get paid you have to target people who
have money to pay you if they're
struggling to get started in their
business they're not gonna pay you
anything because they don't have any
money and that's a lot of business
coaches so what I would look at is
people who are living more established
so I look at one people who have a book
with a major publisher not
self-published
but they have a book with the publisher
especially if it's one that's coming out
because that they want to build up
anticipation promotion for it so where
are you based I'm based in Nepal Nepal
okay so what I would do is look at look
at the major Canadian American cities
and look at their bookstores and see
who's coming that goes
like people who are doing book tours
people were talking about their books if
you're in a bookstore speaking is
because you have a book with a publisher
not because you've self-published so
I'll look at like New York City look at
because you can take clients from
anywhere like you're not gonna get Nepal
clients paying you a lot right it's
gonna be ideally you mean you're gonna
make a lot more from North Americans so
look at look at New York City look at
the Barnes and Nobles the books are
there look at the Manhattan locations
and they have a list of all their events
of all the authors that are coming to
speak there there's a calendar and then
I go city by city the authors they don't
necessarily have to be life coaches they
have to be this does have to be in the
self-help industry right whoever you can
help like if there's an author who's a
speaker you can help them you need
somebody to be a speaker right like you
need to so so like authors are good
start even speaker like look at look at
people who are speaking at major events
look at all the major events happen in
New York City and all the speakers who
are going to speak in there the major
events so Tony Robbins has one coming up
in New York I'm going I'm going there
and meeting him backstage like who else
is speaking on that ticket who else is
gonna be speaking there like those are
people like Tony Robbins may not may not
be your ideal client but but whoever is
on that ticket maybe like people who are
being paid to speak people who have a
book and have been paid by publisher to
create it these are the people who are
good potential candidates for you
because they have money because they're
hiring firms because they care about
their branding in their image people who
are appearing like watch like CNBC like
new shows where they have experts coming
on like people who care about their
branding so the challenge they have is
they have they have money they have the
ideas but you don't know what they're
doing on Instagram you can help them
versus is that there's a lot of business
coaches who have a brand on Instagram
but they're barely making any money from
clients and so they won't have anything
to pay you so I
be targeting people who actually get
paid to speak yeah and get paid to write
books yeah that's a really good advice
man thank you so much like if they're
getting paid 25k to do a speaking gig
yeah right and and your Instagram
strategy can help them get multiple
speaking gigs they're gonna pay you for
that
it's a good strategy what I used to do
nowadays is like I used to go to the
hashtag life goats and there are so many
pretend life goods so it's like really
annoying yeah you want you want to get
the other guys people who want to get
into Instagram but they have an
Instagram but they're not they're not
doing much on it and then show them that
you can bring them a lot of value and
then show them people who look like them
right like for any speaker you could
show them what Gary Vee is doing like
here's what Gary Vee is doing here's why
he's winning he does is one-minute
videos I want to make one minute videos
for you for your Instagram channel
here's one here's what one would could
look like and I'm gonna help mark and
promote it so that you can start getting
more speaking gigs or you can sell more
books that's really good advice man I'm
gonna do it like right after this yeah
great like but the whole thing like your
strategy is great except for the like do
it for free for six months thing that's
not good you should get paid to do it
but it's just the selection finding the
right people I think you should do one
video for free to show them like what it
could look like and match their style
and redo it like you know what like I
hate the color green why did you don't
never put green in your video I never
want to see that right so like match
their brand how important in this kind
of business that I'm doing how important
do you think are referrals and
testimonials and it'll end up being the
whole thing if your strategy works like
if you reach one speaker if you reach
one author and it ends up being you end
up helping them they talk to other
authors and other speakers I'm like yeah
I'm blowing up on Instagram oh how you
doing it haven't got this guy he's
amazing it's from Nepal he just reached
out to me he makes these crazy videos
and they're helped me get more speaking
really what's his name can I meet this
guy it'll end up being the whole thing
but at the beginning you need to do the
outreach to find the people that's every
service based business if you do a good
job in a service based business your
number one source of new business is
referrals but they have to love you like
you have to be doing an amazing job yeah
that they want to share it so I think
your strategy works except for the free
part ongoing it's not six months for
free like make one killer video for free
the only thing is it's the targeting
you're selecting the wrong people
speakers because because they have
videos because you need somebody to
speak but somebody's getting paid to
speak there's a lot of people who will
speak at a local library or YMCA or will
you don't what I'm saying may be but
local like local community event but
they're not being paid to be there if
I'm you I target I target every like
major city in America starting with New
York and LA and look at like big events
where people are speaking out because
they're they're likely being paid to
speak there I want paid speakers I would
look at this speaking agencies there's
there's uh agencies they represent
people to go in to speak so like they'll
be your agent so they'll book you on
deals go through those agency websites
they have like a hundred different
speakers on there at different prices so
they're getting paid to speak I could
target like every single cell every
single New York Times bestselling author
in the self-help industry mm-hmm if they
have any kind of videos where they're
speaking because you still need somebody
to actually speak right most authors
though they do yeah most authors will
speak their ideas so yeah that's that's
a great start even if they have a
podcast like I could animated and put
that on Instagram great
that's much better targeting and then
you have to give them something that
they care about when they look at it
they're like wow like yeah I could
definitely use that versus huh most of
the stuff people send me is just huh
it's okay
but I wouldn't post it so that that then
becomes your challenge like I need
targeting the targeting now becomes
easier now you have a better strategy
then it's making the good videos that
really blow them away and I would I
would prepare them like make them look
like any author or speaker I would
compare to Gary Vee because he's the one
who's the biggest doing this stuff
here's what Gary Vaynerchuk does to sell
more books or to book his speaking gigs
he makes these videos I want to do it
for you the road I can take you yeah you
have great ideas you have a great book
yes I want to help it reach a bigger
audience and here's the strategy
nice yeah cool man good luck also if you
want to know what I think and what other
successful entrepreneurs think about
building confidence check out my new 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 250 4 days for free I will
send you a 30 second a 5-minute video in
the morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description below
if you want to be more confident you
need to surround yourself with things
that make you feel confident realizing
that any big endeavor is the collection
of a lot of small steps that came before
if you're doing work that you love
you're more likely to follow through
you're more likely to do it because it
doesn't feel like work because you love
doing it raise your standard Apple at
the core its core value is that passion
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's suppose to mean if you want
more marketing advice from Tim Ferriss
Richard Branson Robert Kiyosaki and
others check out the video link right
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there marketing market marketing
marketing marketing marketing marketing
market marketing Martin